Democrats tell pollsters what they want
in a 2020 presidential nominee and one
thing is clear Democrats really want a
white guy this should come as no
surprise to those who have traced the
history of the Democrat Party which was
founded by white guy Andrew Jackson
preserved by white guy slaveholders
resurrected by white guy Klansmen and
with the exception of one half of one
guy has exclusively elected white guy
presidents then the government is likely
to remain open as the president signal
was he's willing to cave on funding for
the wall it's okay though don't worry
because Republicans just voted to let
thousands of criminals out of prison for
some reason and transgenderism deals
another brutal blow to the ideological
left
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
today is opposite day today is totally
opposite day I'm upset with President
Trump in the Republicans
I want to compliment Cheng cougar he
actually did something good Democrats
embrace being the party of white men
Republicans cave on the wall they let
thousands of prisoners out of prison we
will get to all of that that bizarre
opposite day
but first let's make it one money honey
with expressvpn with all of the recent
news about online security breaches it
is hard not to worry about where your
data go making an online purchase or
even just accessing your email could put
your private information at risk you are
being tracked online by social media
sites marketing companies and your
mobile or internet provider and everyone
else people looking over your shoulder
man that's why I decided to take back my
privacy with express VPN expressvpn has
easy-to-use apps that run seamlessly in
the background of your computer phone or
tablet turning it on takes just one
click you really need this guys I am
Telling You especially when you consider
the sort of stuff that I look at on the
Internet
you know like daily wire comm when I all
that weird stuff you have to do it and
you'd be a fool not to use Express VPN
you you would be a fool to let your data
just out there don't do it I'm glad that
I I secure my data you should to
expressvpn secures anonymous as your
internet browsing encrypt your data
hides your public IP address protect
yourself for just less than ten bucks a
month do it today find out how you get
three months free at expressvpn comm
slash michael mi CH AE l that's exp ress
BPM comm slash mi CH AE l go and do IT
righ T and o W get three months free
with one year package visit expressvpn
comm slash michael to learn more the
polls are in democrats have looked ahead
to 2020 and they only want white guys
they don't know not women not black guys
not Hispanic people nope
only white guys there was a poll put out
by a group called democracy for America
this was a major poll this was a poll of
94 thousand progressives self-identified
progressives who is the number one
choice for 2020 oh it's not Kamala oh no
no
not it's not Cory Spartacus Booker no no
no no it is Bernie Sanders who in 2020 I
think he'll be a hundred and seventy
nine years old in 2020 s so he will be
well past the constitutional mandate of
being 35 years old he'll be many
multiples older than that so he
certainly can run he might be a little
old but it wasn't even close by the way
Bernie Sanders blew his competition out
of the water
the next closest competitor was Joe
Biden also a white guy but Bernie got
three times as many votes as Joe Biden
you blew it blew it out of the water so
number two was Biden and number three
baito a Roarke now you might be confused
you'd say with a name like bado
that's not a white guy actually it is a
white guy his name is robert francis
O'Rourke he is entirely Irish he is not
at all Mexican
so the first three guys white guys the
first two guys old white guys only when
you get to number four do you get Liz
Warren
she's only 1023 1020 fourths white she's
obviously 1/1000 24th Native American
Indian and then number five you get
Kamala Harris so you actually can trace
gradations of white all the way down to
gamma layers you start with Bernie
Sanders he lives in a Vermont he lives
in basically the whitest state in
America then you get to Joe Biden still
pretty white but you know he's got a
little more Rust Belt vibe then you get
to beta or Roark he's completely white
but he's a fake Mexican then you get to
Liz war and she's also completely white
but she's got a little drop of Native
American only when you get to Kamala
Harris do you get anything even
resembling a racial minority which again
I wouldn't really care about except
Democrats make a very big deal about
being the party of racial minorities and
and women and this and that and then in
reality there's just the opposite don't
just take this one poll this one poll is
not just an outlier moveon.org
that odious left-wing group did another
straw poll and this one did not put
Bernie on top it put bado on top so bado
was on top then Joe Biden and then
Bernie Sanders was number three so again
the exact same top three people born out
again from that
progressive poll now into moveon.org
same three guys different order the
really bad news for democrats is the
hill TV poll of who democrats won for
their twenty twenty nominee the number
three winner there was bernie sanders
old white guy the number two winner was
joe biden also old white guy the number
one winner none of the above
who I guess statistically is a white guy
if you just look at the numbers of
people in the united states none of the
above
you know basically anyone else you've
got a very good chance of that also
being a white guy so all three polls
privileged the white guys this this
again good completely goes over and in
that hill t v-- poll the number fourth
choice was hillary clinton incredibly
number five was elizabeth warren then
you got Camilla Harris then you got Cory
Booker so again you see it's funny I
mean I would make the joke anyway but
you actually do see this born at in the
move on poll the hill TV poll you see it
born at this at these gradations of of
whiteness so the Democrat Party I don't
know that they can really make this
claim that they're the party of
intersectionality that they're the party
of tearing down the mean old white guy
but there's I mean they're gonna make it
anyway they're always gonna make that
claim but it does show that huge gap
between the rhetoric of the Democrat
Party and the reality they say we're for
the people we want the popular vote you
don't really want the popular vote you
want the popular vote if you're a
Democrat because you think that it'll
help you out in certain swing states
Democrats don't want the popular vote
they won't even allow the popular vote
in their own nominating convention they
won't even allow the popular vote in
their own primary campaigns that's why
they rely on super-delegates party
elites to come in and say you're gonna
be the nominee who cares about the will
of the people
okay I've beaten up on Democrats enough
I actually have to switch gears here and
beat up on Republicans a little bit the
White House right now is signaling that
there will not be a government shutdown
here's senior advisor to the president
Kellyanne Conway in a surprisingly
contentious exchange on Fox & Friends
this morning well first of all let's not
all acquiesce to the
still a soundbite that this is about a
wall they're trying to make a wall
four-letter word when the president's
been talking about border security all
along as have the Democrats until he
became president in 2006 they voted for
the secure fences act that included
Schumer Hillary Clinton Barack Obama Joe
Biden 26 Democrats voted for that this
past July 10 of the 15 Democrats on the
appropriate committee the relevant
committee voted for border security okay
oh this isn't about a wall this isn't
about okay and actually later on in this
interview Steve Doocy comes in and and
actually grills are a little bit what's
going to happen to this shutdown why
isn't the government going to shut down
the real reason we know that the
government's is not going to shut down
is that the Senate has voted on a or is
voting on a funding bill to fund the
government through February 8th so it's
a short-term funding bill it's not a
major one but what happens before
February 8th Nancy Pelosi and the
Democrats take control of the House of
Representative this raises a big
question why did Trump back down he told
us I'm gonna be proud to own the
government shutdown I will shut down the
government in order to build the wall
and get five billion dollars to build
the wall on our border Stephen Miller
went on Face the Nation said exactly the
same thing one suggestion for why he did
that
is that he didn't have the votes Nancy
Pelosi made this claim in the Oval
Office we need we need border security
so we knew that President Trump didn't
have the votes in the Senate because he
would need ten Democrats to switch over
but the question was does he have the
votes in the House or not and as as
Steve Doocy brought up on Fox & Friends
Paul Ryan doesn't want the wall I think
that's fair to say I don't think Paul
Ryan wants the wall I think if he did he
could have whipped up the votes but he
doesn't there are a lot of Republicans
in the House who don't really want the
wall they talk a good game when they're
on the campaign trail but they don't
actually believe in enforcing our
immigration laws when they are governing
so my suggestion in all of this was let
the Democrats shut down the government
or let Trump shut down the government or
whoever we're going to blame for
shutting down the government let it
happen
because this is a political winner for
Republicans one is the right thing to do
just for the country and for our system
of laws but two it's politically
beneficial for the Republican Party and
for the president why not let the
Democrats who are now so hysterical so
obsessively committed to open borders
why not let them shut down the
government over that they say keeping
borders open letting thousands of
illegal migrants cross the border make a
mockery of our laws let them come in
willy-nilly 3,000 people a day they're
so intent on that that they're willing
to shut down the government that's a
great campaign commercial that's a great
way to enter into 2019 but they wouldn't
do it
there's an amazing irony here there's a
poll out from Gallup that says that when
Americans are considering all of the
various political problems they think
the number one problem is the government
and the number two problem is illegal
immigration here's an idea how about you
shut down the government to stop illegal
immigration this is a win win this is
killing two birds with one stone or in
the new PETA language feeding two birds
with one scone or whatever idiom you
want to use this is a big win people
don't like the government have rightly
so and they don't like illegal
immigration you're going to shut down
the government and you can get shut down
the government as a tactic to get five
billion dollars to build the wall and
stop illegal immigration for the near
future but they won't do it and this is
frustrating enough now I see the flip
side of this is what leverage does
President from have you shouldn't enter
into a government shutdown if you don't
have leverage to reopen it and the
president doesn't have leverage to
reopen the government I guess the only
leverage would be once the Democrats
take control of the House of
Representatives then then there's really
no point in carrying on so you could
reopen and say okay we've dragged this
out for a month and got a lot of bad
press for Democrats and c'est la vie
maybe we didn't get the funding for the
wall but but so what who cares I just I
understand there's not a lot of leverage
there now President Trump says he's
gonna get the military to build the wall
they'll get money from other agencies
they'll find it some way else okay so we
don't get the wall we are going to fund
the government
looks like the party is gonna back down
on this just like they did twice two
other times this year but at least the
Republicans just voted to let thousands
of criminals out of prison we'll get to
the first act in a second but for a step
act in a second but first let's make a
little money with purple mattress you
know how much I love purple mattress
purple mattress is I'm a proselytize er
for it it is the greatest bed certainly
I've ever owned it is not quite a memory
foam it's not an innerspring it's this
totally separate thing it's gonna feel
like nothing else you've ever tried it
was developed by a rocket scientist I
absolutely love mine it is both firm and
soft at the same time that sounds like
it doesn't mean anything
it does it actually does it's perfectly
supportive it sleeps really cool so it
doesn't bother you in the in the summer
it's just fabulous it's its unique
material is what does this I wish that I
were a scientist so I could describe
what it is but I'm not it feels like you
have this zero-gravity feeling I guess
that's the best way I could describe it
you got a hundred night risk-free trial
if you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
but you're not gonna want to you're
gonna be feeling what I feel in my
boudoir every night backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns free
and home set up and old mattress removal
you're gonna love it right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that is
in addition to the great free gifts that
they're offering site-wide just text
cough fac OVF efe - 47 47 47 that is the
only way to get this free pillow text
cough fa ce o-- v fe fe - 47 47 47 co v
fe fe two four seven four seven four
seven message and data rates may apply
but it's worth it because you'll get a
sweet purple pillow so we don't shut
down the government we don't get the
five billion dollars for the wall but at
least Republicans just voted on the
first-step Act which will let thousands
of criminals out of prison because
that's how President Trump won isn't it
that's how he won his election he said
look we're not gonna stop illegal
immigration but we will let thousands of
criminals out of prison yeah and they
said yeah let them out let them out
unlock the prisoners unlock the
criminals right was that what they were
chanting at they rallies no I don't
think
was they were chanting build the wall
and also lock her up they actually
wanted to put more people into prison
particularly Hillary Clinton this was a
bad idea I you know I I'm a supporter of
the president I'm a big supporter of
this administration they've done so much
good and sometimes they do stuff like
this this first step act is just what a
bad idea Tom cotton was against this
Republican senator and he was a
hardliner he was kind of leading the
Conservatives against this in the Senate
but it failed he tried to introduce some
amendments to kill the bill it just
didn't happen who is supporting this
thing kim kardashian is so great the
ACLU is supporting this Van Jones
left-winger on CNN was celebrating he
was so happy when this bill passed
politics sure does make for strange
bedfellows why on earth are we voting
for this when we could have built the
wall what is this what does this bill do
whenever you come out against this first
step act the criminal justice reform
spring that criminals from prison act
they people accuse you they say you
don't know what's in the bill well I
don't know I'm not an expert on the bill
but but tell me if I'm wrong tell me if
I get any of these bullet points wrong
and then you can lecture me about not
knowing what's in the bill the bill will
ease mandatory minimum sentences under
federal law right now they're mandatory
minimums that judges have to have to use
when they're sentencing people and this
would ease those sentences it would
expand the so-called safety valve so
that judges can avoid them so it puts a
lot more discretion into the hands of
judges which might be helpful to some
criminals but then again when you just
rely on the capricious moods of judges
then you're you're not really treating
people with total equality under the law
you're giving a lot of care to the women
whimsy of judges it would ease the
three-strikes rule so right now there's
a three strikes rule if you get three or
more convictions you will automatically
get a sentence in certain cases of life
in prison now that reduces that
dramatically to 25 years and then the
rest of the law can ease that to make it
even shorter it also restricts the
current practice of stacking gun charges
so right now if
instance this is what you always hear
you say someone shouldn't serve life in
prison for just possessing a little dime
bag of pot for personal use yeah of
course I agree with that nobody
disagrees with that in the whole country
but the people who are in prison for
simple possession how many of them pled
down those charges for much more serious
charges from charges like dealing drugs
you know right right now we're at the
height of an opioid epidemic of a drug
epidemic that is so bad it's actually
helping to reduce the average life
expectancy in the United States and
we're saying that we should go easier on
drug dealers many drug dealers who have
pled down their crime to a simple
possession or something like that and
and what the first step act will do is
now not allow prosecutors to stack gun
charges so if you're a drug dealer out
on the streets and you're packing heat
process prosecutors can stack that on
top of your drug charge now they'll say
no that's okay that's okay the drug
dealer was packing heat because it you
know it's a black market that's awful
and gets Americans addicted to poison
but we shouldn't punish him for packing
heat ridiculous it also increases
goodtime credits that inmates can earn
currently inmates can get up to 47 days
good credits of up to 47 days per year
incarcerated now that increases to 54
which allows relatively well-behaved
inmates to cut their prison sentences by
an additional week for each year that
they're incarcerated but this is also
retroactive which means that the day
this law goes into effect according to
supporters of the bill not critics
according to supporters of the bill
4,000 prisoners will qualify for release
that very day that it goes into effect
the bill will allow earned time credits
by participating in more vocational and
rehabilitative programs and what do we
mean by this rehabilitative program this
is really what the whole bill is about
because they're treating the criminal
justice system as though it's only about
rehabilitation it's not about punishing
people it's not about criminal justice
it's not about to even deterring crime
certainly not about those two things
it's just about rehabilitation it's a
it's a therapy session I don't even know
why we're only restricting it to
criminals why not do it we could all
a little rehabilitation couldn't wait so
now you'll get extra credits if you take
part in rehabilitation programs we also
just found today this broke that the
federal government has paid three
hundred and sixty five thousand dollars
in recent years to the Nation of Islam
Louis Farrakhan's radical organization
the organization obviously bigoted
refers to Jews as termites to go into
prison and rehabilitate prisoners which
actually means radicalized prisoners
into that perverse ideology of the
Nation of Islam that's that's what we're
talking about here when we talk about
rehabilitation programs this is
obviously a fundamental misunderstanding
of the criminal justice system and I
don't know which wing of the White House
or which wing of the Republican Party is
pushing this sort of stuff
it seems so compassionate doesn't it
seemed why we I want people to get out
of prison if they've served their time
if they've been reformed I really do I'm
not just a total hardliner I know people
who were bad people who killed people
who were real bad hombres and they were
totally reformed in prison one guy won't
say his name from New York you know he
is a born-again Christian he's one of
the most charitable people he's like a
saint walking the earth goes to Mass
every day is just an incredible man you
can be reformed in prison I hope that
happens that's a wonderful thing to do
that's not an excuse to spring thousands
of people out of prison long before
their sentences are over with the
dubious evidence that they've been
reformed in some way that they're not
going to go and and now and make it
easier for people who are dealing poison
out on the streets carrying guns while
they do it
to avoid long jail sentences that's not
the way to do it it's a total
misunderstanding of the criminal justice
system another aspect here I this is
like really opposite day a president
Trump's administration is now banning
bump stocks the bump stocks are they're
on you put the bump stock on your rifle
and then you basically hold the trigger
and you can pull the if you run your
hand this is getting a little a little
graphic for a family show but if you run
your hand down the the length of the gun
it will simulate what
what would seem like an automatic weapon
so you can fire more rapidly you can't
really aim at anything so it's not a
terribly useful tool but he's now the
administration has banned these this is
because of that shooting in Las Vegas in
2017 that killed 58 people and injured
hundreds more bump stock was used in
that shooting
boom stocks are virtually never used in
shootings but it was used in that one so
now they want to ban it banning bump
stocks would not have saved a single
life in that shooting there's no
evidence of that that shooting went on
for 10 minutes just pulling the trigger
one one one one one
you could easily kill and injure all of
those people in the course of 10 minutes
the shooter wasn't found for an hour his
by killed himself and then his body
wasn't found for an hour the the bumps a
bump stock man would not have saved a
single life in Las Vegas just as always
happens when there's a mass shooting the
left wing calls for gun control and then
you say which gun control law would have
prevented the shooting which gun control
law would have saved a life and they say
uh I just want to do something well
you've got to do something that's
helpful you can't just do something and
then pat yourself on the back and say oh
gosh aren't ia good person you haven't
accomplished a single thing even more
shocking than my frustration with the
Trump administration in the last week is
I actually think Chang Kyogre of The
Young Turks got something right I know I
know this is shocking this comes in the
wake of Tucker Carlson's common Tucker
Carlson's under fire the left-wing
radical groups are calling for a boycott
of his fox news show and it's because of
this comment we have a moral obligation
to admit the world's poor they tell us
even if it makes our own country poorer
and dirtier and more divided immigration
is a form of atonement previous leaders
of our country committed sins we must
pay for those sins by welcoming an
endless chain of migrant caravans so
he's right about that point he's right
about the white guilt and the ideology
of open borders but did you catch what
word got him in trouble you did it's
yeah it was the dirty said it would make
our country dirtier and just as a very
simple observation poor countries
dirtier than clean countries than rich
countries that's that's certainly the
case they I have traveled to the third
world I have lived in the first world
I've probably gone to the second world I
don't know exactly where the second
world is I've been all over and of
course it is of course poorer countries
are dirtier they don't have the same
resources for sanitary systems and and
things like that so he makes that point
should he have used a different word
maybe are all illegal immigrants who
come people who come here from bad
places are they all dirty when they come
here no at least not for very long you
know you can acclimate to America pretty
well so yeah ok maybe you shouldn't have
used that word is at the end of the
world no I don't think so
and now the left is just jumping on this
to call for a boycott of Tucker's
program they've just been waiting they
call for boycotts of everybody's
programs all the time and you notice the
right doesn't call for boycotts of
left-wing programs very very rarely does
that happen generally speaking we let
them spout their nonsense and and we
just say what we want to say I've never
called for a boycott of Rachel Maddow's
program because if I did I'd be arguing
myself out of a job so I certainly
wouldn't want to do that so shock of all
shocks here on opposite day Schenk huger
of The Young Turks came out swinging
defense of Tucker Carlson i I think as
odious as Tucker Carlson's comments are
he gets to make them when we get to make
the counter-argument it's not a First
Amendment issue these advertisers have
every right to put their ads anywhere
they like they're not the government
okay but as a general principle I
believe in freedom of speech and I
believe that in the marketplace of ideas
and you could say hey that's hokey Jenk
and it's not right and it's you know one
is on a cable news station powered by
billions of dollars that Rupert Murdoch
put in and you guys are online and it's
a totally different animal we'll take
him on anyway and we will beat them
anyway and we're beating them today so I
think they should let us battle it out
but now the sponsors are pulling out I
don't know what you think Anna he's
absolutely right about that I will point
out though he lays this caveat he says
and it's a cable news station and
Tuckers powered by zillions of dollars
from Rupert Murdoch
yeah true The Young Turks has a studio
at YouTube don't they I think I'm
getting that right I don't I don't want
to say anything that's untrue
I am 99.9% sure the Young Turks have a
studio at YouTube which is powered by
essentially the biggest corporation in
the history of the world so let's not
throw stones here but he makes the very
good point why you're right it's it's a
it's private businesses it's it's cable
news it's whatever so people can boycott
it's not a government issue it's not a
First Amendment issue but they shouldn't
just let him say what he wants to say we
can have a dialogue
he gets it they get this exactly right
this is where if the left is smart they
will move this is the sort of thing that
they'll embrace Schenk is still a left
of Lenin on just about everything else
but they're gonna they're gonna be the
snake that eats its own tail if they
keep it up with this censorship stuff
because they're just slowly gonna
destroy themselves and censor themselves
there was this woman this feminist
writer in Canada who disagreed with the
transgender ideology
she's a left winger she's a feminist
writer they banned her from Twitter
because the snake was eating its own
tail because and this is what's gonna
happen to the left it's just gonna
totally destroy itself unless they get
on board with what Genk is saying and I
think that's probably why he's saying it
we have a lot more to get to great stuff
from Dan Crenshaw he is that congressman
war hero you know I was injured in in
battle lost and I and also too speaking
of transgenderism transgenderism is one
of the greatest gifts the left has ever
given us it's ripping down another
leftist fantasy in abortion and some
more craziness at Mount Holyoke College
but first if you happen to like books
with words and I don't I mean I'm sort
of take them or leave them you are gonna
love been Shapiro's latest release the
right side of history
how reason and moral purpose made the
West great it's official release date is
March 19th but you lucky listeners can
pre-order your copy online right now at
any major bookseller trust me it is very
very good it pains me to make an
earnestly nice comment about Ben but
it's really good I read it
an advance copy about it months ago and
it's it's really a good book it's
terrific it fills a real need
I think you will learn a ton from this
book I think it will be extremely
helpful for the culture and I think it's
the most important the second I'm sorry
the second most important book to come
out in the last two years the second
most informative the second best written
book the second most comprehensive guide
to Western civilization in the last two
years if you haven't read the first you
know you got to head over and do that
but Ben's book is really good you should
pre-order it this thing is gonna sell
out in a second there's no question
about it today at 5:30 Eastern 2:30
Pacific Ben will also be taking all of
your questions and blowing your mind
with his wisdom live on air we have got
to stop letting Ben write my damn reads
for this show I'm not gonna say this
anymore all right
eleisha crafts will be there to collect
all the leftist tears so that the great
flood does not happen again if you're on
daily wire.com thank you you keep the
lights on over here offa and my cup if
not go to daily wire.com you know you'll
get everything you get all the shows and
the questions get your mailbag questions
and that'll be tomorrow you get the
leftist ears tumblr this is what you get
it's very very important you're going to
need it we're moving into Christmastime
you know the left has a real tough time
around Christmas they don't like that
word they don't like the particularity
of it they don't like all the joy and
the happiness and the family and the
merriment you're gonna need this you're
gonna need it especially because I'm
dreaming of a white Christmas when all
those fluffy salty tears come down there
they have much more volume than the
liquid you're gonna need probably two of
these go subscribe to Ice go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
dan Crenshaw super cool guy
rising star in the Republican Party
you'll remember him because on SNL that
kid Pete Davidson made a joke about him
and said he looks like a porn star
pirate or something I don't really
remember the joke didn't land and this
was controversial because Dan Crenshaw
is a war hero who lost his eye defending
our freedom yours and my freedom
defending our country and so they kind
of made up Dan Crenshaw was very
gracious about the whole thing and he
even went on SNL and for a fleeting
moment made SNL funny again and anyway
this week Pete Davidson the SNL kid sent
out what was essentially a suicide note
on Instagram and said he doesn't want to
live in this world anymore he's trying
to stick around but he doesn't know how
long he can last he's talked about
depression before and his battles with
mental health there is a suicide
epidemic in this country I've seen it up
close it's really really nasty
it's disproportionately affecting
Millennials teen suicide is up 70% this
really is no laughing matter this is a
real serious thing and so everyone went
to his side
Pete Davidson deleted all of his social
media accounts and Dan Crenshaw actually
gave him a call and it was a stand-up
thing to do and the right thing to do
and here he is talking about it actually
I talked to him personally yesterday and
talked to him for a little bit about it
and you know we don't go back very far
we're not good friends but I think he
appreciated hearing from me and what I
told him was this he everybody has a
purpose in this world God put you here
for a reason it's but it's your job to
find that purpose okay and you should
have a use live that way you should live
that way always seeking out that purpose
not expecting it to be given to you by
anybody else and know that you have
value and that you maybe do more good
than you realize for people especially a
guy like that you know he makes people
laugh sometimes it makes people mad it
makes people laugh a lot you know that's
what we talked about it was it was a
good conversation that's the right thing
to say it's very important to remember
this when we're talking to people on
especially on Twitter but even on the
air in politics or usually the people
everyone's really nice it's only on the
air when they're writing or from behind
a computer screen that they get really
really mean you do have to remember
you're encountering an eternal soul
every person you talk to your you are
encountering an eternal soul see us
Lewis writes about this a lot it's
almost a scary thought because
especially in a culture that's a little
more materialistic we like to think of
everything as just being what we see so
I'm you know this is a this is a golden
wonderful vessel of leftist tears and
you know I can hear it and it's just
that's all it is it's just material my
body is just material when people die
they just turn to worm food they take a
dirt nap they dissolve but that isn't
really true there is a physical world
and there's a metaphysical world and we
are both we are both physical and
metaphysical we have a body and we have
a soul
we have a both of those are intertwined
were not
I know it's fashionable today among
sophomoric atheists to pretend that the
soul doesn't exist but it does and when
you encounter people you're encountering
a soul as well your nice is really hard
I mean especially when it comes to you
the hook-up culture or dating or
whatever you it's very tempting to use
people everyone this is a ubiquitous
temptation I get it but you don't just
use people sexually you can use them
professionally you can use people for
some social climbing you can use people
for I don't know to get a favor out of
them or something and it's it's really
not the right thing to do if you're not
convinced of that as an ethical or moral
matter at least be convinced of it this
way you might see them again someday you
might see these people in heaven that's
what see as Lewis describes you might
see them in another world and you say I
remember when I met you oh gosh I
shouldn't have said that I shouldn't
have done that and so it's very
important I try to do this everybody
fails at it is that's not to say be a
squish that's not to say be a just a
nice guy all the time be really low
energy make your point
fight for what you believe cut be
serious go to rhetorical battle
absolutely but don't say something
you're going to regret don't say
something in the heat of the moment that
you you wish
hadn't said that's true of when you're
talking to a friend or a family member
or some stranger on the Internet
don't you always try to to be able to
defend what you're saying and to be able
to stand by what you're saying
and you know don't be mean just for the
purpose of being mean or cruel you don't
have to do that you can be cutting you
can be brutal
you can totally own the libs without
doing that I said look it's very funny
when people are mean to each other
around the internet it's perfectly fine
it doesn't bother me in that personal
way but it will bother you over time and
it will make you more crass and you more
cruel imagine I mean imagine how this
also could have played out Pete Davidson
the SNL comedian makes this bad joke
about Dan Crenshaw and Crenshaw goes and
he slams him and he's really mean to him
and he says he's a terrible person and
then let's say Pete Davidson followed
through on his threat what would we be
looking at I mean that would be a really
terrible thing you couldn't ever forgive
yourself for something like that so it's
important to remember there are people
there and it's not just people in the
way that we think about people in a very
modern way we're talking about Souls and
you're gonna have to see them someday
and you better not want to
run away from them in heaven because
that's going to be very awkward heaven
is full of light and you can't hide
there aren't any places that you can
hide in up there some other good news
transgenderism is ripping down this
leftist fantasy of abortion now this
actually speaks to the soul as well this
is a story that comes right from the
left which once denied the soul is now
admitting that the soul exists you saw
over the weekend there was that guy
competing for the Miss Universe pageant
so this guy miss Spain is a dude who now
either has had surgery or dresses like a
woman or has had surgery and dresses
like a woman and he didn't win but he
did very well in the Miss Universe
pageant here is what he has to say about
the question of whether or not he is a
woman I'll translate because I assume
most of you don't speak Spanish
this is having a vagina does not make me
a woman I am a woman and already was
before my birth because my identity is
here in my mind not down there I love
this story
I love the the fact of transgenderism in
I mean it's not good for the people who
suffer from the condition but the
etiology is very good for exposing the
bizarre contradictions within the left
because what they've just admitted what
what miss Spain just admitted by the
process of transgenderism is not just
that he was a woman before he was born
but that he was before he was born that
he was anything before he was born what
the pro-abortion left wants us to
believe is that you you don't exist
until the very moment that you are born
two minutes before you're born oh you're
just a clump of cells you're just a
random mish-mosh you don't even look
like a human oh don't look at that
sonogram oh don't know don't feel the
baby kick no no it's just a mishmash of
cells only once you're born do you
become a human and what miss Spain just
said is I was a woman before I was born
and so it's acknowledging the humanity
of the unborn baby what we call the
fetus which really just means offspring
or the embryo or whatever they want to
talk about it's acknowledging that that
is a human life but what miss Paine is
talking about is even further which is
at the heart of the transgender ideology
itself it's at the heart both of the
condition and the ideology which is that
humans are not just physical objects we
have a soul so I might be a man
you can check under the hood down there
you know if everything checks out I've
got whiskers I have a deep voice and a
big Adam's apple I am a man I've got a Y
chromosome but in a non-physical in a
metaphysical sense in a deeper reality I
am really a woman and that this is the
universal claim of transgenderism but in
order for that to be true there has to
be a metaphysical reality there
has to be a soul you have to be
something more than just your physical
body this is a very difficult thing for
the left for leftist materialists for
leftist atheists who say there there is
nothing beyond the body there is nothing
beyond the physical world well if that's
true then transgenderism is even more
ridiculous than it is in a world with a
soul if that's true then what are they
claiming then they're truly just
babbling nonsense
now it's also nonsense in the world
where there's a metaphysical reality as
well but it's at least much more
plausible in that world it cuts against
this and I the the reason this issue is
so good I mean we're the reason why for
the conservative side I'm glad that
transgenderism which actually only
affects 0.2% of the population if that I
mean a very vanishingly small percentage
of the population the reason that this
has dominated the national conversation
is because the left has to work out all
of these issues and challenges that it
poses for its ideology because it poses
a ton of them it just smashes down the
notion that men and women are exactly
the same or the notion that that that
feminism makes either men and women are
exactly the same or they're not exactly
the same either sexual differences are
natural or they don't exist they're just
sort of socially constructed well if
they're Kasauli constructed what is a
woman what is a what is feminism if
gender doesn't really matter at all then
why would someone surgically mutilate
himself go to such great lengths to try
to more closely resemble a woman if a
metaphysical reality does not exist then
how can someone be a man but not a man
really
what does really even mean in that
scenario it raises a lot of really good
questions I think you know we're shocked
by the ridiculousness of it but rather
than exclusively making fun of the
ridiculousness of it we should do that
you know 92% of the time but for the
rest of the time follow that train of
thought think about why this issue has
cropped up in the imagination of
Democrats and left winners it's because
they're extraordinarily confused in
their thinking and this this is
good opportunity to bring some clarity
to it I mean this nowhere is this more
visible than at Mount Holyoke College
Mount Holyoke College is traditionally a
girls-only school the current logo of
Mount Holyoke College MHC has the h and
the sieved combined to form the Venus
symbol that's the the female gender
symbol you know and now this is very
offensive you're not allowed to do this
anymore why because in 2015 the college
decided it would no longer be a women's
only college it would also admit trans
women which is to say men so the college
now is it's it's a women's only college
still but the way they describe it is
it's a gender diverse women's college
it's a not only women women's college
it's a women's not women's college ok
it's a contradiction of a College the
president of Mount Holyoke College lynn
pasquerella said quote we recognize that
what it means to be a woman is not
static just as early feminists argued
that reducing women to their biological
functions was a foundation of women's
oppression we acknowledge that gender
identity is not reducible to the body
right I'm sure those early feminists are
so happy now they're just dancing in
their graves or dancing up in heaven
that now that they're women's only
college isn't is no longer allowed only
to admit women
what a huge striving for a feminism what
a great leap forward so not only do they
say this nonsense but after the protests
of this symbol a Mount Holyoke
spokesman responded and said it is now
evident to us that this symbol the Venus
symbol the female gender symbol has a
long history of exclusion connected to
movements that while trailblazing for
some groups represents the erasure of
others we have thus determined that the
college cannot move forward with a word
mark that references this symbol and it
is true the Venus female gender symbol
does exclude some people namely men the
women's symbol
excludes men because the very definition
of women until five seconds ago was and
is not men that's true it's exclusive
it's not tolerant in the silly way that
we talk about tolerance now but words
are exclusive discrete things are
exclusive this is a pen this is not a
watermelon
that's so exclusive isn't that so
exciting how I want it to be all things
to all people I want to be all things to
all people that's the typical cowardice
of our age we demand to be all things to
our people and when you try to be all
things to all people you are nothing to
anybody when you try to be a friend to
all in reality you are a friend to none
you have to stand for something or you
will fall for anything how many more
simple platitudes can I possibly utter
and where there must be like 20 more of
those this is the mistake that Mount
Holyoke College is admitting that the
competency of Mount Holyoke College the
point the raison d'etre of Mount Holyoke
College is to be a women's college if it
ceases to be a women's college it
doesn't become twice as great it becomes
nothing if the Venus symbol if the if
womanhood is not allowed to be womanhood
the thing that the Venus symbol is
symbolizing the womanhood if if
womanhood is not allowed to be womanhood
then it's not then there is no womanhood
it's nothing well it's not that
womanhood gets better it's that
womanhood goes away and all were left
with is manhood and masculinity which
we're told is toxic so that's got to go
away too and what do we have nothing
it's a race to the bottom it is a race
to emptiness another inconvenient
philosophical logical conclusion to the
bizarre contradictions within leftism
and who do we have to thank for this the
transgender ideology so got to give
credit where credit is due here on
opposite day that is our show we have
got a lot more to get to but yeah sorry
too late get your mailbag questions in
we'll go over that tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael an old show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018